one of the best things that could ever
happen to anybody is hitting rock bottom
for a couple reasons I mean it's it's
I've seen anybody that's ever done
anything big in their lives they will
share with you about a moment of hitting
rock bottom the reason why rock bottom
is very very important is because it
tells you nothing comes easy you know
when it imagine a girl who's always
dated man who she's always broken up
with them and no man's ever broken up
with her if that doesn't happen to her
whoever she marries she may take that
person for granted because she's never
lost somebody nobody's ever broken their
heart one the best things that can
happen to somebody is break up somebody
breaks your heart because it's hitting
rock bottom it's it's feeling vulnerable
it's it's really when we get to that
point we really make some big decisions
for our lives I remember when I hit rock
bottom in Ooty Oh three it was terrible
for me I I couldn't find a smallest hole
in the world to hide I went from I was
twenty-one years old driving an
expedition and I remember I just got out
of the military and we'd go partying
clubbing with our friends and I lost
everything I literally lost everything
and I went in bought a Ford Focus and I
remember we went to this one night club
in Burbank and I pulled up in a new Ford
Focus it was embarrassing because I was
rock bottom and I saw the look on my
friend's face when he said Patrick
you're driving a Ford Focus I said yes
this is what happened it was the hardest
thing to look at that person in the eyes
on hitting rock bottom I remember when I
went to my girlfriend's house at that
time and her father and her looked at me
and saying you driving a Ford Focus
smirk on their face will always be
remembered by me because I'll never
forget that
I remember being lonely and making
decisions for myself and you learn a lot
when you hit rock-bottom I won't I worry
about people who don't hit rock-bottom
early I worry about people who don't hit
rock-bottom in a young age because if
you don't hit rock-bottom
early and it happens to you in your 40s
it's very different and difficult to to
respond to hitting rock bottom in your
40s or your 50s if you've never hit her
before if you've hit her before you know
how to recover from
because there's a formula for it but if
you've never hit it before and it
happens to you it really messes what
people said so instead of a you know you
yourself when you hit rock bottom you
learn you'll learn a lot about yourself
go you'll learn a lot about yourself
when he had rock bottom because you find
out what you really are made up of no
one's ever gonna know anything about you
until you did rock bottom and you'll
learn about you I am driving a Ferrari
right now I'm in a 458 Italia and this
is a dream car of mine that I had and
from going from a Ford Focus to this
this doesn't happen overnight but I
could tell you for the people who knew
me and saw me when I hit rock bottom I
vividly remember all of those things and
this whole lifestyle now is a byproduct
of how you make decisions and come out
of things when you hit rock bottom and
you start realizing this thing goes by
like this life goes by pretty quickly
and how you respond when you hit rock
bottom will say a lot about your life
you